um sie nicht zu lange auf die Folter zu
spannen ja kaum zu glauben Herr
Lauterbach mit seinen Augen nicht
getraut haben aber Schweden liegt weit
vor Deutschland und das obwohl Herr
Lauterbach doch mehrfach behauptet hat
dass Deutschland im Europa Vergleich
besonders gut durch die Pandemie
gekommen seid diese Theorie spätestens
jetzt widerlegt trotz der strengen
pandemie-politik sind in Deutschland
2020 und 2021 pro 100.000 Einwohner 116
Menschen mehr gestorben als statistisch
erwartet viel mehr als bei fünf
Nachbarländern die früher gelockert
haben in Dänemark der Schweiz Frankreich
Österreich Belgien und den Niederlanden
gab es deutlich weniger unerwartete
Todesfälle ebenso im antilog-down-land
Schweden für Lauterbach eine bittere
Pille und für mich das flammende Signal
dass die Politik während der
corona-pandemie endlich aufgearbeitet
werden muss die übliche Ausrede das
konnte doch keiner ahnen reicht längst
nicht mehr aus
ich war gerade ein Israel und das hat
mich sehr überrascht und sehr
glücklich gemacht wie andere Volker mit
dem Thema umgehen diese Sehnsucht nach
Normalität diese Drang einfach das Leben
wieder herzustellen ist etwas was sich
in Deutschland vermisse und ich glaube
das hat auch sehr viel mit einer ganz
großen
Anhängerschaft die wir hier in
Deutschland haben die einfach
jenseits von Studie jenseits von
Maßnahmen einfach diese Normalität nicht
mehr haben will und Corona ist ein guter
gefunden fressen dafür aber ich frage
mich warum wir nicht in der Lage
sachlich und differenziert über das
Thema zu sprechen und warum Karl
Lauterbach immer noch vom Keller
Varianten spricht und in der Zukunft
eigentlich sehr pessimistisch blickt ja
ich wage die These dass die Deutschen
Todeszahlen auch damit zu tun haben
könnten dass bei uns ja nicht
unterschieden wird ob jemand an Corona
oder mit Corona gestorben ist und das
war ja Absicht bei die corona-politiker
und das verschwommen zu lassen wenn man
damit besser argumentieren kann ich
glaube dass andere Länder das besser
auseinander sortiert haben hier war das
RKI nicht dazu Unterlage ist es bis
heute gar nicht und Lauterbach
argumentiert ja immer mit den hohen
deutschen Todeszahlen die so zustande
kommen um damit einer harte
corona-politik fahren zu können ich muss
jetzt sagen man stößt ja jeden Tag auf
irgendwas was ihn eigentlich aus dem Amt
Hebeln müsste jetzt hat er ja seit
neuestem
ein Gesetzentwurf zunächst mal vorgelegt
über die Triage meint dass bei der
Einlieferung von ernsthaft erkrankten
Menschen in Kliniken entschieden werden
muss wenn es zu viel auf einmal sind von
den Ärzten entschieden werden muss wer
wird behandelt und wer nicht also wer
wir zuerst behandeln und wer danach
da gibt es da in diesem Gesetzentwurf
gab es eine
ex-posttriage das ist das perverseste
was ich überhaupt je gehört habe das
hießen nämlich dass wenn Patienten
eingeliefert werden die
rettungswürdig sind andere Patienten die
schon auf der Intensivstation liegen
dort aus den Betten geholt werden und
die nachgelieferten dort reingelegt
werden das hat er das hat er erstmal
vorgelegt und dann am selben Tag wieder
auf dem Verkehr gezogen weil er aus dem
Verkehr gezogen weil er natürlich wusste
oder ahnte jemals hat es ihm gesagt wenn
du das vor der Landtagswahl in NRW noch
mal ja dann
muss natürlich eins sagen dass das eines
nicht aufgeht mit Angst und immer mehr
Horrorszenarien die Menschen zu
domestizieren also
einzukerchen und das alle jetzt
hinterherlaufen wir alle wissen dass wir
auf Sicht gefahren sind in der
coronazeit es war was neues und
natürlich jeder Politiker egal welcher
Partei
unterstelle keinem etwas Schlechtes
hatte vor so gut wie möglich dieses Land
und die Bürger durch diese Krise zu
bekommen aber jetzt sind wir nach zwei
Jahren viele haben die Nase einfach weil
sie können auch nicht mehr auch
wirtschaftlich nicht und da ich auch
wirtschaftspolitisch Sprecherin unserer
Bundestagsfraktion bin weiß ich was die
Folgen nach wie vor von Corona sind und
das müssen wir auch abwägen und letzter
Punkt dass er immer wieder von neuen
killervarianten spricht ich denke jetzt
mal an Kinder an Jugendliche auch mein
Neffe hat in der coronazeit Abitur
gemacht sie glauben doch nicht dass so
junge Menschen das nachholen können was
sie da verpassen
und zwar hauenberg oft und gerne ich
auch auf Herr Lauterbach ein aber die
Hauptzeit der corona-pandemie war es ja
Jens Spahn von der Union der der
Gesundheitsminister war wenn man sich
jetzt die WHO-Studie anschaut und die
Zahlen anschaut ist die Union daran
interessiert die corona-zeit
aufzuarbeiten und vielleicht auch mal zu
schauen was haben wir falsch gemacht die
schulschließ unsere Kindern sie haben
selber angesprochen ihr Neff wurde auch
bei anderen Kindern was dazu geführt hat
wird es da von der Union einen Bericht
geben naja wir müssen eins mal sehen es
gibt nicht die corona-zeiten Corona
hatte ganz unterschiedliche Phasen
gehabt und übrigens was Corona auch mit
uns als Bevölkerung gemacht hat am
Anfang große Angst und auch Dankbarkeit
dass die Bundesregierung damals war ich
Mitglieder der Bundesregierung dass wir
da auch wirklich besser durch die
Anfangszeit kam als zum Beispiel in den
USA oder Bergamo haben Sie noch die
Bilder vor Augen wie Leichen aber wir
fahren jetzt doch nicht so gut durch die
Zeit wie wir jetzt auch gerade gesehen
haben wie man denkt verschiedene Zeit
Phasen die die Empörung über Herr
Lauterbach ist ja deshalb so da weil er
ja immer als Kritiker aufgetreten ist
als derjenige der alles viel besser
macht und wir müssen ehrlich eingestehen
auch bei Wissenschaftlern gibt es immer
sehr unterschiedliche Meinungen deshalb
glaube ich muss Politik es aushalten
dass sie auch als Berater
unterschiedliche Meinungen hat nur dann
glaube ich
sieht man auch raus aus diesem Kasten
denken vielleicht von dem was man hören
will letzter Punkt die Länder haben aber
auch nicht glaube ich ganz so gut
mitgespielt ja da würde ich gerne Frau
Neigel fragen was halten Sie denn von
einem corona-untersuchungsausschuss den
ich ehrlich gesagt schon gerne sehen
würde dann auch mit Blick auf die Jahre
der Union ich hatte das für extrem
wichtig ich glaube eben nicht was Sie
gesagt haben dass alle immer nur im
besten Sinne gehandelt haben wenn man
ein bisschen tiefer reinblickt sieht man
zum Beispiel dass das Gesetze gibt die
zum Beispiel den Bettenabbau gefördert
und subventioniert haben ins Krankenhaus
vor strukturgesetz Paragraph 12 jedes
Bett bringt einer Klinik dass man abbaut
zwischen 6.800 Euro bis 12.000 Euro das
ist richtig viel Geld da haben klinikend
in fetten Reibach gemacht das weiß die
Regierung auch die in der sie waren und
natürlich in der coronazeit
2016 ab 2016
Kliniken abgebaut doch mal aber die
Betten abgebaut in den Kliniken während
der corona-zeit während wir Betten
aufgebaut haben also da müssen wir
glaube ich präzise sein dann bin ich
gerne präzise im Jahre 2021 hat man ich
glaube
60 Kliniken geschlossen und im Jahre
2020 ungefähr 30 ich bin wahrscheinlich
sogar drunter also das ist zum Beispiel
passiert und dann gab es natürlich auch
was mit Personal zu tun das ist Personal
nicht da ist nicht nur mit Bettenabbau
es ist auch ein Anreiz für Kliniken
einfach auf eine gewisse Art und Weise
Geld zu machen die haben ja auch Betten
einfach schlicht untergreifend leer
stehen lassen haben Geld kassiert ich
sage das deswegen weil das sind
natürlich auch Dinge die die Regierung
wusste weil das
krankenhaus-strukturgesetz ist seit 2016
existent und wird genutzt es gab aber
auch zum Beispiel innenpapier das nannte
man dann auch panikpapier vom
Innenministerium das wurde dann auch
geliebter armer Mann der das dann
irgendwie weitergegeben hat dann gibt es
nicht mehr da ist nicht mehr dort da
standen natürlich dann auch wo haben Sie
die Daten her weil man muss sagen es ist
sehr schwer Welt hat das veröffentlicht
die Welt hat darüber berichtet ich meine
auch das hat mit dem Bettenabbau wir
müssen das natürlich schon verifizieren
Naturgesetz einfach reingucken ist ein
Gesetz gibt es immer noch offiziell seit
weil es ist sehr schwer zu erfassen dass
die Bundesregierung wirklich extra
Betten abgebaut hat also das würde ich
sagen aber das Gesetz ist ja durch die
Politik geschaffen worden und es wurde
da auch ordentlich genutzt und es gab
halt eben wie gesagt noch zusätzlich gab
es noch diese zusätzlichen Pauschalen
für die Intensivbetten die extra
freigestellt worden sind die zum Teil
leer standen und aber trotzdem bezahlt
worden ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie der
die Pauschale war zwischen 5000 €, also
das Wissen andere besser aber die gab es
eindeutig da haben also Menschen
tatsächlich im Hintergrund auch Gesetze
genutzt und Strukturen genutzt die sagen
wir mal ja mit Steuergeldern einfach
in Deutschland der Fall gewesen ist dass
Menschen die auf die Intensivstation
mussten nicht auf die Intensivstation
konnten weil jemand Betten nicht belegen
wollte ganz definitiv aber da gibt es
viel zu viele Leute die sagen sie
durften nicht operiert werden hätten
eigentlich operiert werden müssen ich
glaube wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen
differenzieren auch es geht um die
Intensivbetten sie haben eben die
Intensivbetten genannt bei den
Intensivbetten ging es darum ob
Krankenhäuser überlastet waren also in
den Regionen wo wir hohe
corona-inzidenzen hatten oder eben nicht
und das in dieser Zeit wo wir
corona-infektionen sehr infektiös in den
Kliniken hatten hat man nicht dringend
notwendig Operationen zurückgestellt
viele sind auch selbst freiwillig davon
zurückgetreten weil sie nicht ins
Krankenhaus wollten das ist auf Dauer
ein Problem im übrigen wenn man schaut
auf das Thema Krebserkrankung erzählt
Zwischenfragen die Sache mit der
gesundheitsüberlastung des
Gesundheitssystems sie sind also immer
noch der Meinung des Gesundheitswesen
war überlastet
noch mal es gibt nicht das
Gesundheitswesen ich glaube wir müssen
hier schon differenzierter reingehen ich
komme aus einer Region Rheinland-Pfalz
eine Stadt Bad Kreuznach hat zwei
Kliniken so wir haben aber auch
innerhalb dessen in kleineren Städten
Kliniken die waren ziemlich schnell
überlastet kann ich Ihnen sagen wenn in
einem Dorf in der Großfamilie Corona
ziemlich heftig zugeschlagen hat war
diese Klinik dort das System dort
überlastet aber Entschuldigung immer
schon immer das Intensivstationen auf
einzelnen Kliniken ausgelastet waren und
dann noch irgendwann anders
transportieren dazu war es auch richtig
man wusste ja nicht was auf uns zukommt
was mich stört ist diese
Eindimensionalität wir reden ja seit 10
Minuten über das Virus aber Corona ist
nicht nur das Virus es ist auch die
Maßnahmen und die Nebenwirkungen oder
die nachfolgen von von die lockdowns und
die Einschränkungen die wir gehabt haben
ich habe wirklich angeschaut auf
Lauterbach Twitter in den letzten zwei
Jahren und ich habe kein einziger
Erwähnungen für die psychische Folgen
auf die Menschen die für Studien gibt es
Herr Lauterbach sagte mal dass er nicht
sicher ist ob die Zusammenhänge jeder
vierte Erwachsene weiß gerade psychische
Auffälligkeiten da
Jugendliche die zwei Jahren nicht ihre
Normalität zurückbekommen haben diese
Druck die Kinder werden verantwortlich
auch für die Erkrankung von Erwachsenen
das hat massive psychische Folgen die
wir schon sehen und es gibt diese
Entscheidungen nicht bezüglich auf die
körperliche Versorgung sondern auf dem
psychischer Versorgung heute müssen Sie
ein Jahr warten in Berlin bisher im
psychotherapieplatz haben und Lauterbach
gibt es kein einziges Wort dazu deshalb
würde ich gerne sehen dass wir mit
dieser alten Politik brechen in der Zeit
in der Pause die wir jetzt haben
weggehen von diesem Besessenen
Gesundheitsminister der
Mutter drauf wartet dass es wieder
losgeht mit einem Killervirus dass wir
einen neuen Gesundheitsminister oder
Gesundheitsministerin kriegen wenn ich
sie so höre vor Glück da kann ich mir
vorstellen sie werden das in einer CDU
geführten Regierung sagt jetzt nichts
sagen Sie jetzt nichts und das bei der
gleichen Gelegenheit auch der ki-chef
Villa ausgewechselt wird wenn das RKI
hat keine präzisen zahlen mehr seit
geraumer Zeit wenn die nur noch
geschätzt aber so ausgewiesen als seien
sie genau penibel berechnet worden das
sind sie nicht das heißt Deutschland
tastet sich durch den Nebel und da drauf
sitzt ein Minister der schon das nächste
Virus beschwört und damit muss
eigentlich wenn wir jetzt nicht die die
ukraine-krise hätten müsste die Politik
dieser Bundesregierung jetzt schauen und
jetzt die Gelegenheit ergreifen
diese ministerstuhl zu räumen und neu zu
besetzen und das RKI neu zu besetzen
bevor wir das Thema be noch eine
Rückfrage an sie Frau Klöckner viele
machen sich ja jetzt schon wieder
Gedanken über den Herbst sind jetzt in
der Opposition nicht mehr in der
Regierung aber müssen wir uns Gedanken
machen dass es im Herbst wieder losgeht
mit Lockdown Maske tragen und so weiter
ich hoffe nicht ich eines müssen wir uns
glaube ich klar machen wir werden mit
dem Virus leben und leben müssen und wir
müssen die Schützen die besonders
anfällig sind und tajörges hat es ja
vorhin auch angesprochen diese
Unterscheidung mit Corona oder an Corona
gestorben zu sein
ich kenne Fälle die haben heftigste
Verläufe gehabt ganz heftige weil ich
kenne auch junge Menschen die gestorben
sind zwei in meiner näheren Umgebung
aber ich kenne ganz viele die es noch
nicht mal mitbekommen haben dass sie
Corona hatten oder hatten es ganz leicht
ihn wir müssen damit leben und ich
glaube was ganz wichtig ist ein paar
Dinge die wir ja auch wirklich geübt
haben Hygiene spielt kann immer nicht
schaden keine Frage und wer eine Maske
tragen will soll eine tragen aber mein
Blick geht Richtung Kinder geht Richtung
auf die Schule was wir die jungen
Menschen was ist für uns Ältere sind
zwei Jahre ja ist ein bisschen nervig
aber für junge Menschen in der
Entwicklungsphase was das heißt was das
auch an ich sage immer Schäden für das
ganze Leben mitbringt das sind Relation
zu setzen das ist mir ganz wichtig dass
wir alle daraus auch lernen ich möchte
auch daran erinnern was nicht alle aber
viele Lehrer diesen Kindern angetan
haben den die Lehrer haben für sich
argumentiert und nicht für die Kinder
absolut und sie wollten in Sicherheit
sein sie wollten zu Hause bleiben sie
wollten maskenpflicht in der Klasse
haben und was mit den Kindern passiert
ist war in gleichgültig das ist eine Art
von beruflichem Egoismus den man
eigentlich nicht ertragen kann